What I want to do in this video
is step through the program
that we wrote in
the previous video
to really understand what's
happening, line by line.
And get a little bit of
an intuitive understanding
for for loops and variables.
We're going to do it
for a specific example.
We're going to do an example
where the user inputs--
so when the user is
prompted to input a number,
the user will
input the number 3.
We're just going to assume that.
And I've picked a
low number so that we
don't have to keep looping
through this forever.
So this video can be
of a reasonable length.
So right when that happens, when
the user inputs the number 3,
it the assigns the variable
number to be equal to 3.
And there's two ways that
you can think about this.
I tend to, what I do in
any programming language,
when I think of a variable,
I tend to view it as bucket.
So I have a bucket
called number.
And in that bucket, when
the user inputs a 3,
if the user inputs a 3, I'm
sticking a 3 in that bucket.
Python is a little bit
different than some languages.
And the more correct way-- and
they're both kind of intuitive,
I think, if you think about
it-- of viewing of variable
in Python, is to think of the
variable as referring to the 3.
And I say that
because, in Python,
if you change a variable's--
let's say right under this we
wrote number is equal to 2.
We didn't do that,
but if we said
number is equal to
2, what Python does
is it actually leaves
that 3 there in memory.
And then it would point
to the number 2 instead.
It wouldn't obliterate the
3 and just put a 2 there,
the 3 still exists.
And that's important
when we start
doing more complex or nuanced
things with more fancy data
types.
But let's rewind all of this.
For the sake of
this program, you
can view it either way,
a bucket with a 3 in it.
Or you could view
it as a label that
is referring to a 3 someplace
in the computer's memory.
Now the next thing
that happens is
that we have another
variable called product.
And we assign product
to be equal to 1.
So I'm going to do the
same two representations.
So we've set up another
bucket here, called product,
and we are assigning, we are
putting 1 in that bucket.
Or you could say that
product is a variable.
It's a label that
is referring to a 1.
And then we get to our for loop.
And this is probably
the confusing part.
So we have for i
in range of number.
So literally the interpreter
says OK, what's number?
Well, in this case, number is 3.
So this is going to be
evaluated as range of 3,
in our particular example.
Range of 3.
And once again, how did
the interpreter know that?
It's said range of number,
number's a variable,
look up the number variable.
OK.
3 is sitting in it, so I'm
going to put a 3 right there.
Or look up the number variable.
The number variable is
pointing to the number 3,
so I'm just going to put a 3
here and take a range of 3.
And we saw in the last
video that if you evaluate
just range of 3, range of 3 is
equal to a sequence of numbers,
0, 1, 2.
So it creates a sequence
of three numbers,
starting at 0, up to
that number minus 1.
And what the for loop
does, is every time
we go through the for loop,
it executes this code.
It executes this code
that's inside the for loop.
And we know it's inside the for
loop, because we indented it.
And the most used
convention is Python,
is to don't use the Tab.
You'd press Space four times.
And that tells the
interpreter, anything
at this level of indention
happens every time
we go through the for loop.
And when we start the
for loop, the i variable
is going to start at 0.
So the first time we go
through the for loop, i
is going to be the first
element in this sequence.
Then, when we go to
the for loop again,
i is going to be the second
element in the sequence.
And then when we go
through the for loop again,
i is going to be the third
element in the sequence.
And then we go to the
for loop and it'll
try to assign i to another
element in the sequence
and say, hey, wait!
There are no more
elements in the sequence.
And then it'll break
out of the for loop
and then continue on with
the rest of the program.
So given that, let's
think about what
happens for the
particular example
where the user inputted a 3.
So range of number
is going to evaluate
as-- I wrote up here, 0, 1, 2.
Let me do it this way.
Let me write it over here.
So it's going to be, 0, 1, 2.
And the first time
through the loop,
i-- so I'm going to use this
convention right over here.
The first time through the loop,
i is going to refer to the 0.
Or if we use this convention
over here, the first time,
as we go through
the loop, i, you
could view it as
a bucket that is
going to be assigned the
first element of range of 3,
the first element
of the sequence.
It is going to be 0.
And then we execute
what's in the loop.
We reassign, so we have
to reassign product
to be something new
right over here.
And what is this something
new the first time
we go through the for loop?
i is 0.
0 plus 1 is 1.
So the first time we
go through the loop--
let me do that in a color you
can see-- the first time we
go through the loop, this
is going to be 1, 0 plus 1.
Product is 1 this first
time we go through the loop.
Let me do it in the same colors.
So i is 0 plus 1, so we get 1.
1 times 1 is 1.
So product will be
assigned to be 1.
So product will be reassigned to
be 1, which really isn't going
to change anything,
because it's already 1.
So it was 1 before.
You multiplied it by 1
and reassigned it to be 1.
So I could write, cross out 1,
it's now going to be 1 again,
but I'll just leave it as 1.
Or we can just say it's going
to be reassigned to be 1.
So nothing really has
changed that first time
through the loop.
But now, interesting
things are going to happen.
So now we'll go back to
the beginning of the loop.
And now, i will be the
next element in the loop.
So now, i-- let me delete
this-- it will be reassigned
to be the next
element in the loop.
So now i will be 1.
That's what the for loop does.
It makes i each of the items
in the sequence in order,
going through them.
And now we execute it again.
Now we go look at
product times i plus 1.
Product is still 1.
i is now 1.
So 1 plus 1 is
now going to be 2.
It is now going to be 2.
So 1 times 2 is going
to be our new product.
So the new product, it
was 1, but now we're
multiplying it by 2 and
assigning it again to product.
So the new product
is now going to be 2.
So the product
variable is now 2.
And then now we
try to loop again.
And now this time, i
will be the next element.
i is going to be the next
element in the sequence,
right over here.
Or we could say i is
going to be reassigned
to 2, the next element
in the sequence.
And we try to evaluate it again.
So now we go into the for loop.
Product is now 2.
i is now 2.
2 plus 1 is 3.
So this whole expression
over here is 3.
So we have 2, product is
now 2, times i plus 1.
i is two, so i plus 1 is 3.
So you have 2 times 3
3 is now going to be 6.
So the new product times
i plus one is now 6.
So this is now going to-- let me
do that same blue color-- this
is now going to be 6.
And now we try to execute
the for loop again.
And the for loop's
going to say, hey,
let me reassign i to be the
next item in this sequence.
It tries to find the next
item in the sequence.
But it says, wait, there is
no next item in the sequence.
So we're done
executing our for loop.
So there's nothing
left in our sequence,
so we're done with our for loop.
Now we break out of it.
And we go to the next
line in the program.
So the next line in the
program is, literally,
just print the product.
And at this point, we just
want to output the product.
And the variable
product is now 6.
And actually, one thing
I should have done,
this entire time
is, I was sticking
with the bucket representation.
But the product on
this representation,
here, it started referring to 1.
It got reassigned to 1.
But then it got assigned to 2.
So then this
reference went to 2.
And then it got reassigned to 6.
So if I were to be consistent
with this representation
over here, every time product
is referring to another number,
or you can view it as a bucket,
for the sake of this program,
where it keeps
getting reassigned.
And what was cool
about this, is when
we're done with this for
loop, the number that's
sitting in the bucket product,
the variable product--
or you could say, the number
that the variable product
is referring to-- is the
factorial of the number
that the person inputted.
It's the factorial of 3.
And if you remember,
3, the symbol
for factorial is an exclamation
mark, is equal to 3 times
2 times 1.